[Music]
in switching sides news submitted by
corn I to sewer trout weights it again
corn I'd sewer trout it's mad gaps corn
on tour trout I don't know where to get
these things horrid ice or trout it just
sounds like a real trust your tracfone
after which our corn so try you know
wide American man is giving up his US
citizenship to become Chinese that's so
opposite become Chinese citizens just
completely become a Chinese the surgery
[Laughter]
it's illegal to smoke weed out there the
Google's banned like that's 32 terrible
things all of all of their billionaires
are trying to run away here even their
[ __ ] top politicians are trying to
[ __ ] run away here the nudists room
there's not that many women to men well
he is married yeah what part of that man
oh he's already married he's taking his
wife with him he's married to a Chinese
woman oh that's why she wants to be with
the family but you know does he have to
give it up he has to so in order to
become a Chinese citizen you must give
up whatever citizenship you have from
your original doing that what's his deal
because he's [ __ ] China all the way
there's thousands of dollars people do
this so yeah that's I'm saying I'm
wondering why is that a headline then
you know is that really weird to you cuz
to me
yeah it's it's [ __ ] weird that anyone
would want to be a expat in mainland
China
I get Hong Kong Shanghai or other but
but mainland China Shanghai is part of
mainland China oh I thought they were a
part of us something else Taiwan Hong
Kong
well Hong Kong is is it mainland China
no but Hong Kong has its own passport
I mean I guess he was trying to say
things that are not oh yeah yeah I guess
I want to because it's just not a
country that people are trying to run
away from run away to or look like China
is a country that a lot of Chinese
people are trying to get away from there
don't want to raise their kids there and
they want to leave so a lot of things
it's like the government issues too like
pollution is terrible out there yeah
wait you said a lot of people a lot of
people people come from here I want to
go to America Europe Australia so it's
like a lot of you all over the world
I wanna go to they want to go and they
give up this is a shift cuz I think a
lot of you think it's the future for
some reason I I mean they of course a
lot of business stuff pops off too but
they have the worst pollution in the
world they're like they don't even get
more benefits like people that are
foreigners get paid more than Chinese
citizens and certain companies yeah okay
so this guy's name is Brent he's
originally from Florida he moved to
China back in 2010 actually he moved
back in 2010 he moved to Hong Kong he
was a chief representative of an online
company but now he lives in mainland
China and so he got married back in 2011
he has a stepdaughter with his wife and
yeah now he wants to become a Chinese
citizen he already obtained the Chinese
like the green card for China which is
like the red car [ __ ] gold dragon
like it looks like a Chinese new your
money envelope that's a brass hand off
that is a proper hand off it was not
expecting [ __ ] Hulk Hogan's brothers
like idiot like I've been trying to go
to the US and you're over here you want
to trade places buddy
what is why that red and gold you did
what I get
mean I get it it's like what you know
love I think that's it's a headline
because so many people want to be the US
citizen possible not only that but it's
so hard to become a Chinese really why's
it so hard well maybe because they got
an overpopulation thing going on here so
out of 600,000 foreigners only 7356 have
become permanent residents between 2004
and 2014 a number over time I bet out of
600,000 people yeah only 7356
have become - that's [ __ ] crazy
selective is [ __ ] I've ever heard
superstar like that in ten years
yeah but now apparently foreigners can
become permanent residents a little bit
easier because that figure has gone up
163 percent from the previous years
that's only still like that's nothing
yeah I know for a fact though white
dudes could make some good money out in
China though they you know they be
hiring fools to like pretend like
there's somebody yeah
theme parks or like whatever British
towns are grand openings they just want
white guys to stand there in like
British soldier uniforms or whatever
really yeah don't have conferences where
they just pay a random white dude to
like pretend he's like this famous
doctor from the US and does like give
conferences I got off the plane in Japan
briefly because I was head I was
connecting they were looking at me like
I was a [ __ ] celebrity right I was
walking around people are taking
pictures with me shut up yeah and they
were like looking at me like oh they
like Captain America Captain America
just watch it YouTube no it wasn't like
they were actual beds like no they were
like what the [ __ ] look I was like a
strange and you know they do that
they'll take pictures of random like non
Asian people there David asked yes or
Josh - yeah yeah when we were at the
temple in Kyoto
she was just hanging out and she's a
bunch of schoolboys came up and said can
we take
chat with you and she's like why course
she was so we can jack off yeah he's
like no no like I wasn't there she's
like why did they want to take pictures
with me I'm like cuz you're white if
they Paul you've never seen a white
person in person but yeah so brent is a
virtual employee combating financial
fraud in case you guys were curious what
he does in China he beats up financial
fraud damn he's got a lot of work in
China yeah I'm sure the gang it like
that [ __ ] happens over there you can
just get paid to stand outside of a
grocery store or some [ __ ] we're in a
business suit as well yeah no literally
that's what's happened like they do that
they pay dudes from here do that I heard
that they pay people to work in the
company to just pretend work in the
cubicles so then like when they have
business meetings with other companies
they'll be like check it out we have all
these white guys working for us not
something that means we're legit cuz it
makes their company legitimate Wow they
just important just get any white guy
have them stand in a suit outside and be
like Macaulay Culkin's here and
everyone's like oh [ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] had
a business idea alright so let's get all
the white homeless guys here you know
clean them up yeah it didn't send them
to China for work and then we can create
like a temp agency kind of thing like
hey you could visit China you just got a
chill it's amazing yeah till they just
start smoking crack it's like why is
this business guys smoking crack in the
business it's a businessman peeing on
the wall why the yelling out random
words like Toki's culture with him know
that no recent thing was like literally
does a clothing brand who was trying to
like pop off out of China so he like
hiring a random like black dude from the
stage brought him out and said he's the
owner of supreme but he's a dude oh they
were doing like a collaboration and [ __ ]
that's
that walking shade had a whole press
conference and everything it was good as
you can see my partner is black and
probably on the street work of it he uh
yeah he's official we're doing a
partnership they also have the
girlfriend and boyfriend for rent - I'm
gonna go visit your family and then
they're tired of being like bothered by
your grandma are you married yet so you
rent a girlfriend for a day and you get
to go to your family your friends we
have that out here I mean it's not as
tall that's working exactly I don't know
but none of those girls look like you
could bring them home to family
sometimes oh the high-end ones do they
look mom is five and a half sometimes
the nuns he's saying like sometimes
there's a girl wearing a [ __ ]
see-through fish in that outfit when
you're gonna go to Thanksgiving Sderot a
mom is she
our escort service should be called
wholesome escorts like they just very
wholesome family they gotta know how to
speak true yeah you know you gotta seem
like that's a great business model for
the homeless and right escorts and
homeless escorts kind of be dressed like
they went to church or something yeah
it's how both of these could go terribly
wrong - I'm just saying you know but I
mean the homeless one clearly that one
it's cool cuz its [ __ ] like you know
it's different you know this is like
they could pee on the floor it's all
good they already pee on the floor
one [ __ ] bottles at the restaurant
yeah it's cool and then the the the
wholesome escorts like I don't even know
where to recruit you know like where
were you dude you gotta hit they're
funding their college oh dude there's
tons of people who go to China right now
to like I know a bunch of people who
went to China to teach English and then
we know how [ __ ] of teaching which by
the way but they go to China and they
get paid to like Korea yeah that's a big
thing in Korea mad people go
teach English as the highest-paid in the
world to teach English you know what
there's a lot of people that speak
English and Kriol is really surprised
you have anyway so Brent and his wife
here they mentioned that they are board
members of this charity group and for
that donate about six thousand one
hundred fifty dollars every year in the
face of forty eleven students across
China
so he's loving his life in China and
then he said it's not that he doesn't
love America or like that he hates
America or anything is just that he
loves China and Chinese people more so
he's giving up his it makes sense though
cause like what if what if he was a
loser here and he had nothing going for
him but out there like he's got this
like nonprofit organization he has like
you know a girl that he married all this
stuff like there's a life for him out
there and out here
he was just [ __ ] feeding alligators
and [ __ ] wondering what to do what is it
man he's just another guy who looks like
he makes liquor in his garage yo but
then out there he look he's like an
indigenous [ __ ] name
that's sometimes that's all it takes you
go to a different place you can be a
whole other person somebody it's like a
rare thing yeah founder of Supreme in LA
you're just a random dude yeah exactly
you're nobody but in China you are the
owner of supreme that's all you white
guys out there looking for a brand new
future yeah you can go to China and be
somebody America
you're just another guy just playing
video games in your mom's basement but
in China you could be a pretend CEO
straight up you better really flex your
white privilege when you go out there
that's that's when you get to really use
white privilege right and when you're
there make sure it's all JK sent you for
a 15% fee we don't even know if this
shit's real I'm so ignorant
[Music]
[Applause]